Speaker 1: After Donald Trump gave this
interview to Sean HANNITY last night,
a number of Republicans, including even
on Fox News, said, This is not so good,
this is not so good. First example is former
Republican Congressman Jason Chaffetz,
also a current FOX contributor who says this was
a very bad interview. Trump gave a bad interview.
Speaker 3: Jason, you.
Speaker 4: Said overall you thought President
Trump did a very. Poor job in the interview.
Why? I thought Sean HANNITY did a good job. But I
watched that and I thought, Where is Donald Trump?
I voted for Donald Trump twice. I have defended
him countless times. I thought he was horrific.
That was the worst interview I've seen the
president do. He was whining. He was complaining.
Speaker 1: He he does that in every
interview. But it was particularly bad.
Speaker 4: The victim card. Time and time again.
And then after that, he complained that, you know,
somebody had endorsed was now running against him.
And I. I thought he was absolutely horrific.
He's the former president of the United States.
Act like it. He didn't in that interview. Wow.
Speaker 1: Wow. And then even Brian KILMEADE,
when he weighed in about it, one of the
hosts of Fox and Friends this morning saying,
you know, he's kind of punching down and
he really should not do that. And as far
as KILMEADE goes, this is about as strong of
a criticism of Trump as you will ever hear.
Speaker 4: Bob Dole and George Bush 41 one
did tear each other's eyes out. John McCain
and George W Bush never really got over the
personal animosity as they locked horns.
Speaker 3: You could say that
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton,
it got extremely personal and they've.
Speaker 4: Never been closed since, even though
they worked together for a short period time. So
this is not unusual. But our usual attack on Roger
Santos would be I respect him for what he's done,
but I'm the one with international experience. I'm
the one who did the Abraham Accords. I'm the one
that made Naito pay up to 10%. I'm the one that
made sure that Ukraine wasn't invaded on the way.
Speaker 1: I mean, a lot of those
things are lies, but. Okay.
Speaker 4: Gave them weapons
to defend themselves, not me. So you.
Speaker 3: Point out. Yeah. It seems
to me the tactic.
Speaker 4: More
traditionally would.
Speaker 3: Be. Yeah. Ron,
at 44 years old, still a lot. Well, look at what.
Speaker 4: I have done in four years. And these
are the same players. I like to go back and finish
the job. And he's been very nice. Nikki Haley. I
think he's been deferential to Mike Pompeo and
Tim Scott. I can't imagine saying something bad
about Tim Scott. But with Ron DeSantis, he sees a
threat. But I think that his best offense as the
front runner would be don't punch down, but don't.
Speaker 1: Punch down, says Brian KILMEADE. So
listen, this is the start. This is the start. And
we will see if it continues of some Republicans
saying this entire obsession with DeSantis thing,
the attacks, the criticisms, the punching down,
as Brian KILMEADE calls it, the whining, as
Jason Chaffetz called it, this isn't good for
Trump. Now, I think the counterpoint to this is
that Trump is so far ahead and despite allegedly
facing an imminent arrest, he is polling more and
more strongly against the Santos, who meanwhile,
is on a book tour and getting tons of favorable
press and softball interviews. And DeSantis is
polling is decreasing. So while I agree with
the criticism, I don't know that Republicans
care about Trump whining and punching down and all
of the things that he's doing. And also it doesn't
seem like they are flocking to DeSantis in the
way that at one moment it was predicted that they
would. The next step is, is Ron DeSantis going to
run or isn't he? If anything, the recent polling
over the last 10 to 14 days declining might get
DeSantis to reconsider. But we're going to watch
it. Some Republicans not at all pleased with this
latest disoriented interview on Fox News by Trump